[Müzik]
Evet Herkese merhaba
Şu an burada olmak bu sahnede olmak
inanın gerçekten çok heyecan verici
Belki biraz Klişe gibi gelse de
anlatılan Bunca şeyden sonra bu kadar
şampiyonluk kazanmış bir insan Evet hala
bu sahnede Sizin karşınızda
heyecanlanıyorum
elime birkaç not içeren kart aldım Çünkü
hızlı otomobil kullandığım kadar yarış
kazandığım kadar iyi bir konuşma
yapabileceğim konusunda kendime Çok da
fazla güvenemedim Umarım aradaki açı ve
eksikleri kapatır diye düşünüyorum
esasında bugün sizlere anlatacak çok çok
uzun bir hikayem yok çünkü henüz ben de
23 yaşındayım
daha henüz Kendi hikayemi bile
tamamlamamışken buraya karşınıza gelip
sahnede milyar dolarlık şirketlerinin
ceo'ları gibi işte Okulu bırakın sokakta
yatın hayallerinizin peşinden Koşun
yerlerde sürünün gibi enteresan
tavsiyeler vermek gibi bir niyetim
kesinlikle yok Çünkü ben de böyle
yapmadım Ben sizlerle aslında
burada hayatta başarılı bir hikaye
yazmanın nedenleri bir çalışma özveri ve
sabır istediğine anlatmaya paylaşmaya
gayret edeceğim
Bunun için de önce sizlere Ben kimim ne
yaparım kısaca ondan bahsedeyim 5
yaşında
Babamın da bu sporun içinde olması
sebebiyle otomobil sporları ile çok
erken yaşta tanıştım
ve Dediğim gibi şu an 23 yaşındayım
yaklaşık son 5 senedir de sporu
profesyonel olarak yapıyorum
profesyonel bir sporcu olmanın ne kadar
zor olduğunu çok iyi bildiğim için
hayata ve kariyerime karşı adımlarımı
hep çok sağlam atmaya çalıştım bunların
başında da
şu geldi hayata karşı bir B planı
hazırlamak bir b planım olmasını istedim
ve bu yüzden ağır spor kariyerime rağmen
Aynı zamanda da eğitim Hayatım ara
vermedim ve geçen sene Okan Üniversitesi
havacılık yönetimi biriminden mezun oldu
17 yaşıma kadar
ailemin sağladığı imkanlarla ve çeşitli
küçük sponsorluklarla kariyerime bir
noktaya taşıdım ve bu sayede 17 yaşında
profesyonel bir sporcu olmaya artık hak
kazandım diyebilirim
şimdi buraya çok küçük bir parantez
açmak istiyorum Benim kariyerimdeki
kırılma noktalarından biri olduğunu
düşündüm Hatta belki de en önemlisi
olduğunu düşündüğüm bir olayı anlatarak
Aynı zamanda benim için Sportif
gelişimin dışında hayatım içinde çok
önemli bir ders oldu seni 2016-2017
falan o zaman daha da gencim Hatta genç
değil Biraz gençle küçük arasında
hızlıyım yarışlar kazanıyorum kendime
güveniyorum ama aynı sene dünya
şampiyonasında Start oluyorum carting de
ılık şampiyonu oluyorum Bütün bunların
arka planında da hep bir belirsizlik
için de üzüyorum Yani hep bir sponsor
arayışı hep bir hayal kırıklığı hep
sürdürülemeyen küçük maceralar ve
ailecek benim spor kariyerime ve
hayatıma çok büyük bir yatırım yapıyoruz
çok büyük bir Efor sarf ediyoruz ama
hiçbir şekilde bu sarf ettiğimiz eforun
karşılığı kadar bir geri dönüş
alamıyoruz
Bu da özellikle benim gibi bir sporcu
için içimdeki sahip olduğum
performansı ve potansiyeli bilip çeşitli
imkansızlıklar yüzünden bunu sahaya
yansıtamamak son derece yapıcı bir durum
dönemin Federasyonu Başkanı Serkan
Yazıcı benim 2017'de şampiyonlar
şampiyonasına davet etti şampiyonlar
Şampiyonası nedir Adı da üstünde zaten
branşında şampiyon olmuş bu pist
olabilir ralli Olabilir
carting olabilir Offroad olabilir
pilotların şampiyon olmuş pilotların ve
aynı sene Türkiye'yi uluslararası ayında
temsil eden milli başarılı sporcuların
buluştuğu ve kendi aralarında yarıştığı
bir organizasyon formatı son derece de
keyifli bir format Ben 2016'da dünya
şampiyonasında Ülkemizi temsil ettiğim
için katılmaya hak kazandım Ve henüz
yaşımda orada
karşılaştığım rakip olarak karşıma çıkan
İnsanların çoğunun
kariyeri benim yaşımdan fazlaydı
fakat buna rağmen iki günlük bir
formatta yapılıyordu yarış ilk gün 60
pilotun arasından bir eleme yapılıyor ve
ikinci gün finalde 16 pilot yarışıyordu
ben ilk gün 60 pilotun Arasından en iyi
zamanı yaparak finale 1 olarak katılmaya
hak kazandım bu kadar önemli ismin
arasında ve ertesi gün de yarı finalist
olarak ilk şampiyonlar Şampiyonası
macera mı nokta alalım
ve birdenbire
pistte etrafımız Türkiye'nin en güçlü
takımlarının yöneticileri sarmaya
başladı oldukça şaşırdım bu duruma biri
hemen ertesi hafta evini Belçika Hayat
bir testte götürmek istediğini söyledi
diğeri de ondan sonraki hafta bir
toplantı ayarlamak istedi
ve bu beni oldukça etkiledi ve şaşırdım
Aslında şok edici bir hafta sonu
geçirmiş oldum İzmir'de hediye yarış eve
dönüyorduk ailecek İstanbul'a Babama
sordum baba dedim ben bugün alışla
gelenden farklı bir şey yapmadım Ben
zaten hep bu kadar hızlıydım
potansiyelim de vardı bugün değişen Ne
oldu Neden bu isimler benim her şeye
altına aldı dedim ve babam çok değerli
bir şey söyledi bana düne kadar
kabiliyetinin ve potansiyelinin biz
farkındaydık artık herkes farkında
o gün şunu öğrendim
kendinizin ne kadar iyi yetiştirirseniz
yetiştirin ne kadar zor bir şey veya
Harika bir şey yapıyorsanız yapın bunu
yapmanız bir yere gelmek için yeterli
değil bundan pazarın da haberdar olması
gerekiyor
şimdi bu uzun Parantezi kapatarak devam
ediyorum az önce bahsettiğim
tekliflerden biri olan beğen ve Türkiye
Borusan Otomotiv motorsiklet takımının
teklifini kabul ettim ve artık
profesyonel bir sporcu olarak kariyerime
başladım
Henüz daha ilk sezonunda Ehliyetim bile
yokken Türkiye'nin en genç Diss
Şampiyonu oldu
hani
inanılmaz bir sezon oldu Evet pistte bir
kahramanım kameralar şampiyonluklar Show
ama Pistin dışına çıktığımda eve gidecek
bir otomobili kullanmak için ehliyet
sahibi bile değilim ya beni babamın
götürmesi gerekiyordu ya da bir otobüse
minibüse binmem gerekiyordu aynı sene
içerisinde ve bir challenge'da yarıştım
ve orada da şampiyon oldum
Böylece
Aslında bu çifte şampiyonluk kazanmanın
benim için kupalardan
ve başarılardan daha da önemli olan
getirisi şu oldu
otomobil sporlarına yatırım yapan büyük
markaların büyük sponsorların ve büyük
takımların Bana da yatırım
yapabileceğine Onlara kanıtlamaktı bu
çifte şampiyonluk işte bana bunu
kazandırdı ve ben bugün şu an bu sayede
karşınızda
2021 Avrupa Kupası gençler şampiyonu
aynı zamanda Balkan gençler şampiyonu
Redbull sporcusu Castrol Forte
Türkiye'nin 1 numaralı pilotu ve milli
sporcu olarak karşınızda bulunuyorum
bütün bunları yaşadıktan sonra
Ben artık sporun hayatın hızlandırılmış
bir simülasyonu olduğuna inanıyorum yani
hedefler Çabalar başarılar
başarısızlıklar hayal kırıklıkları
ve daha nicelerini barındırıyor spor
Tıpkı hayatımda olduğu gibi
Bu yüzden şimdi sporumu yani işimi
hayatla örtüşen bir perspektiften
sizlerle paylaşmaya çalışacağım
otomobil sporları maalesef zengin sporu
olarak namsı almış ve öyle olduğu
düşünülen bir spor Halbuki Benim ailem
zengin değil
otomobil sporda bir ekipman sporu
Öncelikle iyi bir otomobile iyi bir
takıma tırlara garajlara mekanik
ekiplere ve daha bir süre ekipmana sahip
olmanız gerekiyor ve bu imkanlar
ulaşması hiç kolay imkanlar değil Bu
yüzden bu imkânlara sahip takımlarda
sadece en büyük ve en başarılı takımlar
bu noktada Bir sporcu olarak bir ralli
pilot olarak da başarılı olmanın yolu ya
çok zengin olmak ki az önce söyledim
değilim maalesef ya da bu güçlü
takımların birinin pilotu olmak
bu konuda Umudumu yitirip vazgeçmek
istediğim
dayanamadım artık pes etmeye çok
yaklaştığım oldu ama
yenilgiyi kabul etmek her zaman mücadele
etmekten çok daha zor geldiği için
mücadele etmeyi hiçbir zaman bırakmadı
Benim mesleğim Ali
doğası gerekli gereği çok uzun
solukluymuş mücadele Hatta şimdi size
ofisimde ağırlayabilirim Kısa bir süre
bir yarışın içinde onlarca Etap var ve
bu onlarca etaptan oluşan 7-8 tane yarış
var bir sezonun içinde
bütün bu maraton olarak
adlandırabileceğim sezonun sonunda da
her şeyi en iyi en eksiksiz ve en hızlı
şekilde yapan bu maratonun sonunda
şampiyon olarak
Tıpkı Aslında hayatta da olduğu gibi
bir yarış deyip geçmeyin onlarca
değişkenle aynı anda mücadele etmeniz
gerekiyor karar almanız çok önemli
kararları çok kısa sürelerde almanız ve
bu kararların sorumluluğunu taşımanız
gerekiyor yükünü taşımanız gerekiyor
her yarış başka şehirde veya Başka
ülkede oluyor Hiç bir yarış birbirine
kesinlikle benzemiyor yarışlar benzese
bile sürekli rakipler değişiyor yani Bu
sporda statik olmak sizin için başarılı
olmaya giden yoldaki en büyük
engellerden biri sürekli interaktif
olmalısınız sürekli pozisyonunuz
yenilemelisiniz ve zinde olmalısınız
Tıpkı hayatta da olduğu gibi
rallide her Etap sonucunda her yeri
sonucunda rakiplerimizle kendimizi
kıyaslayıp ona göre bir strateji
belirliyoruz bazen çok hızlı gitmek ve
yarış kazanmak gerekirken bazen
egolarımızı sindirip egolarımızı bir
kenara koyup belki de üçüncü dördüncü
olun o yarıştan değerli puanlarla dönmek
gerekiyor Yani bizi rakiplerimizin önüne
Taşıyan şey Evet yeteneğimiz hırsımız
çalışma azmimiz Ama onların önüne
taşıdıktan sonra orada kalmamızı
sağlayacak olan şey de kesinlikle
attığımız oluyor
aynı hayatta da olduğu gibi
son olarak konuşmamın başında da
söylediğim gibi sizlere başarı için şunu
yapın bunu yapın gibi şeyler
söyleyemeyeceğim ama ben kendi hikayemi
yazabilmek adına neler yaptım sizlerle
bunu kısaca paylaşabilirim
profesyonel kariyerime başladığım günden
beri hedefimde tek bir şey vardı o da
bir gün dünya şampiyonu olma potansiyeli
taşıyan bir takımda bir pilot olup
İnşallah bir günde dünya şampiyonu
olmaktı ve ben bu hedefimden bir an
olsun vazgeçmedim
bu hedefe ulaşabilmek için yeniliklerden
kaçmadım Risk almaktan kaçmadım
her şeyi hızlı Uyum sağladım ve çok
çabuk konsantre oldum
kimsenin beni demotir etmesine izin
vermedim enerjimi ve hedeflerimi sadece
benim gibi düşünen insanlarla sadece
benim gibi düşünen insanlarla paylaştım
ve onların vizyonları ile bir araya
getirip kendime daha büyük imkanlar
Yarattım
Sadece yeteneğime güvenip Ben zaten iyi
bir sporcuyum diyerek fırsatların benim
önüme gelmesini Beklemedim Ben imkanlar
yaratmak için çalışıp yeteneklerimi
ortaya koymaya hala çalışıyorum yani
Kariyerim için hem çalıyorum hem de
söylüyorum diyebilirim
konsantrasyonumu da alacak hiçbir şeye
müsaade kesinlikle etmiyorum babamın
bana anlattığı bir şeyi hep aklımda
taşıyorum birçok da unutkan bir insanım
babam bana şöyle demişti
başarı için çok çalışmak yetmez işini
yaşamak gerekir Ben işimi yaşıyorum
Haftaya da bir erişim var Evet aslında 7
gün sonra Yarışıyor olacağım ve inanın
hala şu an aklımın bir parçası sizlere
bu konuşmayı yaparken haftaya yarışta ne
olacağını da bu işte işimi yaşamak böyle
anlatabilirim size
Kariyerim her zaman sosyal hayatımın
önünde tutuyorum Elbette ot gibi de
yaşamıyorum sonuçta 23 yaşındayım ama
önümde eğlenmek için çok fazla zaman
olduğunun bilincindeyim ve bunu
Unuttukça da kendimi hatırlatmakta
ısrarcı oluyorum
sadece benim değil
Hepimizin bir şampiyonluk hedefi var
umarım hepimiz bu ülkenin şampiyon
evlatları oluruz biliyorum hiç Kolay
olmayacak ama kesinlikle çok gurur
verici olacak teşekkürler
[Alkış]